after we had made the short film
actually
people kept on watching it and saying
this should actually be a television
series
it's been what 11 years or so since you
started on this filmmaking journey
something can you talk about the most
amount of effort that you've put toward
making a feature and what have been the
biggest challenges
for you and sarah
yeah i think it's been
yeah
10 11 years since we've really been
actively making stuff
um the biggest
effort we've
put towards a feature
well i have two two kind of thoughts
about that um the
the the biggest effort we put towards
the future is a script that we had
written two years ago
that we
called fender bender and it's the road
trip comedy the kind of film that we
love
and we had produced a sizzle reel to
really give audiences or prospective
investors producers
sort of a visual
idea of what the film might be
and i think we'd we've gotten that
script into the hands of a lot of
production companies a lot of big
production companies
um
and that's
that's you know and and i gotta say
all of them passed there wasn't one
company that was like oh let's you know
let's pursue this but just the fact that
you're getting them in there we were
really excited about that um because
that is like a positive sign that people
are liking it enough to start passing it
around like it's not just going to those
friends or you know your your family or
whatever but like it's going to people
who are moving the script farther along
um
and
you know i i feel like we had a lot of
momentum
behind that project and then of course
the pandemic happened and so i think
and not just us i think i think there
were a lot of people who
you know just just lost a little bit of
that that momentum and everything they
were building towards
so that was probably the hardest um or
the most effort we've been put into a
feature so far
another thing that happened to us was
really interesting is that we had made
a couple of years even before that
we had made another short a proof of
concept short film that we were hoping
to adapt into a feature
and
you know we had the feature script ready
and somebody had found our feature
script um an actress had found our
feature script
you know a prolific television actress
you know had been around and on shows
that we all knew
and she
passed it to a producer and they
actually approached us about adapting it
into a television series which is
something we've never done
and
it's kind of interesting how these
things sort of happen because while we
were after we had made the short film
actually
people kept on watching it and saying
this should actually be a television
series
and sarah and i were like oh yeah that's
a you know that's a good idea we hadn't
really thought about that
but people kept on saying it people kept
on saying it and of course we were kind
of locked into that
that you know that uh
that narrow view that no it's got to be
a feature film you know we made it to be
a proof of concept short and now it's
got to be a feature so
we'd written it as feature but then here
were two people who
wanted again we were hearing to adapt it
into television so we actually signed a
deal with them to
adapt this short into a television
series and we spent about a year working
on that
and of course you know as
can happen so many times
projects you know even though you're
super excited about them and you you
really want them to go forward and
there's a lot of momentum behind it
for whatever reason
they they end up falling through and and
things don't always come to
fruition the way you wished they would
um
[Music]
but i'm using that example just to
illustrate like you never know how the
project is going to come alive we had
written a script wanted to make it into
a feature
and then you know something happened
that sort of you know set us back
but we had also had another script that
we wanted to make into a feature and we
were making that into a television
series so
i think you don't really know how
everything is going to fall into place
always so you just got to be ready to
kind of go wherever you know
kind of go um
with your best path forward
and so going into something new do you
always keep that in the back pocket of
like
this this may don't get too excited i
want to be on board and ready
but it could fall through and protecting
yourself almost so
protecting yourself is i think
absolutely crucial i think
again since i've done this for so long
and since i've seen so many things
throughout you know
my career and just the different
jobs that i've done
and just different projects that i've
been involved with you know
yes absolutely i think that's crucial
that you know
you know yes be excited about something
and
and really want it to happen and really
do everything in your power to make it
happen but
you know sometimes things will
fall through and it's just completely
out of your control and
and maybe sometimes it's not but
but i think
keeping um
your
expectations kind of in check until
i think until you're
i would even say you know this even goes
back to like my time as an actor
you know actors can
book a really and this is this has
happened to me this has happened to so
many friends that i know you know you
can book something really amazing and
you can shoot the part even you know you
can you can book it and you can be on
set
and then when you're watching it
you're cut out
you know and i think that same sort of
mentality must apply to the filmmaking
side that like
i would never really consider something
done until i'm literally
at home watching it or i'm in a movie
theater watching it you know things
always happen you know
best intentions i've seen
people and friends make films we were
talking about this earlier sometimes
it's taken these people years but i've
seen films that have
really and i've even been involved in
films like that as an actor where
people invest so much time and so much
money and the film
never gets released ever
people have never seen it it's sitting
on a shelf at somebody's house you know
and it's really unfortunate when when
things like that do happen but they do
happen so i would say
it is really
crucial and maybe
maybe you know something you should
start if people haven't really worked on
it or thought about that really
do kind of get yourself used to
um
just things
you know falling through but everything
will run its course and i think um one
of the ways i've
sort of
started to protect myself from that
maybe is to
to we like to have just a a couple
things going on
you know maybe what's what's the uh
what's the phrase don't put all your
eggs in one basket and i think for for
me and for sarah and for our production
company that's been really helpful
is that you know we're trying to
just have a few things um
that we're working on so that if
something does fall through you move on
to the next one
and you're going with that one and
seeing where that one can go and then
maybe that one will fall through maybe
not and then if so you go into the next
one but i think that's really
um important um but i think you know
yeah when i if if someone is just
um starting out or or thinking of
getting into this
it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen you're gonna you know
things
things fall through
you don't seem jaded to me how do you
keep yourself upbeat
very refreshing
i think um
yeah
not that i'm putting you on the spot or
anything but you seem very upbeat to me
yeah i think um
ah yeah how do i do it uh because
it is true like when
when you get so attached to something
it's difficult i mean i i do i feel you
know when when when a project does fall
through it's like ah
you just feel like you were so you know
you were so close or you you know so
many pieces were falling into place and
then this one thing sort of like sucks
the air out of it you know it is it's
it's really um it can feel
you feel terrible it's it's you know
it's really like um
deflating and and you just it's like ugh
again but
i think
you do have to realize that you know
it's it's
and kind of we were talking about this
earlier too i mean it's a career it's
like it's a the perseverance thing and
it's kind of like you're in it for the
long haul
at least that's how i've always felt
and um
and i think yeah you just you know it is
good to diversify yourself so you're not
putting all your eggs in one basket so
if something falls through you know
that's it that's everything you know
you're out of la you're out of the
business
i think
you really do need to have a good
attitude and
and um
and just yeah be able to sort of
overcome it and um
yeah for me i think i think um
being able to
to have a career
and to be able to um
i should say something that's helped me
has been
being able to just always think about it
that way i guess to think about
maintaining a a career not just
you know
a one one hit or something like that
um
and i think yeah lately
it really has felt for me a lot better
having multiple things going on
so that if something does fall through
because it will
that i can kind of put my focus on the
next thing
you